maintenant pour le pays du big euros et
la tarte plan b c'est à colmar que nous
vous emmenons en week-end colmar qui est
la capitale des vins d'alsace mais aussi
vous allez voir bien plus que cela finit
vogel et reaching et joseph pasquier
[Musique]
pour un peu on s'y croirait la
ressemblance est frappante
pourtant nous ne sommes pas à new york
mais à colmar la statue de la liberté
réplique exacte de sa grande soeur
américaine une oeuvre du sculpteur
colmarien auguste bartholdi événement
c'est qu'elle est à new york mais nous
ne savions pas qu'il y en avait une
autre à colmar de nombreuses oeuvres
jalonnent le centre historique de colmar
comme le fameux petit tonnelier tout au
long de sa vie le célèbre sculpteur est
resté attaché à sa ville natale
impossible de passer à côté du musée
unterlinden c'est l'un des plus visités
de france
bienvenue aux mises en terminale merci
si le musée a été récemment rénové le
cloître calme et reposant n'a pas changé
depuis le moyen-âge
c'est un couvent un ancien couvent de
religieuses du xiiie siècle et diriger
son parti à la révolution française
c'est devenu une prison une caserne de
lanciers et en 1853 le musée ouvre ici
ce musée à la réputation mondiale
renferme un chef-d'oeuvre absolument
incontournable
le retable qui se naïma était pas en
15/100 12
il est composée de onze panneaux
représentant la vie du christ et celle
de saint-antoine qui était supposée
soulager la maladie de l'ergot de seigle
redouté au moyen-âge son auteur matthias
grünewald voulait une oeuvre pour
frapper les esprits apaiser les
souffrances mais on est vraiment une
oeuvre forte qui puisse inspirer réforme
peut-être la frayeur mais aussi la
lanière fois en personne qui venait
avant 7 heures le musée est situé non
loin du centre historique maison
alsacienne rues pavées composent la
carte postale de ce quartier très visité
nous arrivons au coeur de la cité
historique de colmar
ap la krutenau qu'on surnomme aussi la
petite venise en référence aux nombreux
canaux qui la parcourt alors c'est un
clin d'oeil évident la cité des doges en
italie mais nous allons la découvrir un
peu plus en détails suivez nos la
rivière l'aure littéralement le poireau
en alsacien donne son caractère à ce
quartier préservé depuis le moyen-âge
pour découvrir l'histoire de ce cours
d'eau emblématique de la ville nous
avons rendez vous avec un guide
bateliers fonctionnaires et vert qui
était autrefois utilisé par les
maraîchers ont donc étudié le cours
d'eau pour transporter leurs productions
en partant de leur chant qui se trouvait
à l'extérieur de la ville et tous les
geôles d'aller vendre leur production de
fruits et légumes en ville une balade au
fil de l'eau à seulement 6 euros un
petit prix pour une découverte insolite
la barque à fond plat permet d'apprécier
la quiétude de ces canaux mais aussi les
anciennes maisons à colombages présente
tout au long du parcours
à l'époque l'agencement des poutres sous
les fenêtres avait sa symbolique losange
croix de saint-andré des signes de
prospérité
prospérité les couleurs ont également
une signification déjà autrefois on
trouvait des maisons et la scène colorée
ça n'est pas récent alors pas avec
autant de variétés mais notamment le
rouge et le bleu et est souvent utilisé
le bleu et est principalement utilisée
par les catholiques et le rouge les
protestants 1 depuis des siècles colmar
est mondialement connue pour son
vignoble
une autre facette de la ville c'est
aujourd'hui encore la capitale des vins
d'alsace
alors nous sommes en fin de journée nous
sommes un petit peu en retard pour la
dégustation nous avons rendez vous chez
l'un des deux derniers vignerons de
colmar chez martin yu dans la famille on
est vigneron de père en fils depuis
quatre générations et les visiteurs
viennent ici profiter du charme de cette
maison du xviie siècle ancien relais de
poste mais aussi goûter au vin blanc
d'alsace
en alsace on travaille sur cette affaire
6 blanc et un rouge donc si mannaert le
muscat le pinot blanc
le riesling pinot gris le gewürztraminer
air et en rouge le pinot noir
nous allons maintenant découvrir un
autre endroit typiquement alsacien la
winstub restaurant convivial et
traditionnelle
nous sommes au fer rouge un restaurant
emblématique de la ville de colmar c'est
aussi le bon endroit pour manger
quelques spécialités locales et faire le
plein après une journée bien chargée
alors à table et en alsace comme dit le
proverbe c'est toujours bon et c'est
surtout beaucoup
les menus sont copieux rustique est
finalement assez simple à préparer en
spécialité le cadre quelque chose que
vous trouverez nulle part ailleurs en
dehors de l'alsace dans le b que tout
est affaire de cuisson se mélangent
d'agneau de porc et de boeuf mariné doit
cuire longuement sous une couche de
pommes de terre mais vous pourrez aussi
goûté à la tarte flambée ou à la
choucroute aux poissons les autres
spécialités locales et bon appétit
coût total du repas pour deux vécu of
boisson et café compris
46e
il est temps de rejoindre notre chambre
retour chez notre vigneron du centre
ville c'est notre bons plans du week end
dormir dans une maison centenaire une
expérience bien loin du traditionnel
séjour à l'hôtel garder le cachet
[Musique]
dépaysement garanti confortablement
installés dans ces vieux lit à l'abri
des colombages demain nous continuerons
à découvrir colmar en attendant passé
une bonne nuit pour débuter notre
deuxième jour à colmar nous allons
prendre un peu de hauteur en santé et
philippaerts un chat et l'ascension
demande de bonnes jambes
la collégiale saint martin autre visite
insolite elle arrive au paradis là et
après avoir grimpé 244 marche nous nous
sommes effectivement rapprocher du ciel
et si vous êtes à peu près à sa cause m
lucien le gardien de la tour tenait à
nous faire découvrir cette vue
imprenable et un beau spectacle
malgré nos jumelles les cigogneaux
restent cachés dans leur nid mais les
assises de saint martin martin comme je
les ai baptisé voyez donc heure après
cette séance d'observation retour au
centre historique pour profiter une
dernière fois du microclimat colmarien
la ville est l'une des moins pluvieuse
de france direction les halles couvertes
pour découvrir un produit typiquement
local au caractère très prononcé le
munster c'est un fromage qui sent qu'ils
sont forts mais par contre le fromage
est très délicat un fromage au lait de
vache emblématique de la région dont
l'origine remonterait à charlemagne
il est produit dans les vosges par des
fermiers de montagne à goûter absolument
on voit qu'il n'a pas la texture est
très méfiant l'occurrence nous par
contre c'est vrai que l'odeur et tu es
là et là et je ne cherche pas si vous
voulez on a des produits qu'il faut
imaginer que les gens peuvent tenir un
petit peu quand même une dizaine de
jours chez eux quoi peut-être un dernier
souvenir de colmar à condition d'être
bien emballé
au total ce week end nous aura coûté 160
euros avec le munster dans nos bagages
est les bons plans on peut aussi en
trouver et on va tout de suite vous